Another factor that determines the way
a disease is expressed has to do with
whether the functions that says that it
is affecting our fixed or adjustable.
Okay.
And whether a function
is fixed or adjustable,
depends on its sensitivity
to the environment.
Some developmental and physiological
processes are very sensitive to
environmental change. That would include
glucose metabolism and blood pressure.
Others are rather insensitive.
For example,
DNA replication and Purin metabolism are
not very sensitive to the environment.
Sensitive reactions evolve
to be adjustable and
insensitive reactions evolve to
be fixed,
so adjustable reactions are
buying flexibility at the
cost of vulnerability to
dysregulation, insulin resistance
and type two diabetes. For example,
insensitive reactions are
robust to dysregulation,
but they remain vulnerable to genetic
defects so they are more likely to undergo
catastrophic failure.
Where is adjustable reactions are
likely to undergo a sort of progressive
failure?
Let's unpack them.
Fixed functions are
insensitive to the environment,
highly conserved control core biological
processes and are disrupted by single
catastrophic mutations.
They are responsible for rare men.
Delian diseases such as
cystic fibrosis or progeria.
Adjustable functions are
sensitive to the environment.
They vary within and between species
that are constantly shaped by natural
selection. They're directly
involved in local adaptation.
They control physiological adaptation and
do civil responses and reaction norms.
They are affected by many genes,
often polymorphic who's
frequencies change under selection.
They caused predisposition to
diseases of mismatch such as obesity,
type two diabetes, asthma,
hypertension and so forth.
Yeah,
so a few comments on fixed processes.
These are some of the examples of
catastrophic failure due to mutations.
Core biological processes are fixed.
They include DNA replication,
transcription of actin,
Cytoskeleton and so forth.
Major features of the body plan
are fixed by developmental control.
That's the number of heads,
legs, arms, digits in the eyes.
These are all mutations affecting heads,
digits and I's mutations.
Disrupting such traits can have
catastrophic effects which you see here.
They are often caught by quality control
of Gametes of Zygotes and concept I
when they're not caught,
they result in major birth defects.
Yeah,
adjustable features vary on the different
time scales that we have already
visited,
so physiological adaptation is
occurring in fractions of a lifespan.
Acclamation up to about a
lifespan and development.
Developmental plasticity
at about a lifespan.
is often irreversible.
Acclimation is often
achieved through Rio Stacy's.
That is changes in the set point of the
homeostatic feedbacks and physiological
adaptation is usually regulated
through a homeostatic feedback loop.
Okay.
An example of an adjustable processes,
glucose distribution in the body.
It is controlled by insulin.
It's set points change during pregnancy
to privilege the fetus so that more the
fat and the skeletal muscle of the
mother becomes more insulin resistant to
maintain a higher glucose
level in the blood.
That can then be taken up by the
developing fetus and during infection.
The same kind of switch will occur to
privilege the immune system. So the uh,
skeletal muscle and the fat cells become
insulin resistant to keep the glucose
level elevated in the blood so it
can be used by the immune system.
This kind of adjustability
comes with a price,
the diseases of homeostasis,
which include insulin resistance
and type two diabetes.
Yeah,
the symptoms of type two diabetes or
excess thirst, frequent urination,
constant hunger, and the longterm
complications of heart disease,
strokes, kidney failure, and amputations.
So it was very adaptive for evolution
to design and adjustable process to
regulate glucose distribution in the body,
both to aid and pregnancy and
to aid in disease defense.
But it created a vulnerability
that allowed a type of
disease to arise that can
be very debilitating,
particularly in older people.
To summarize, fixed traits are
insensitive to the environment.
They're deeply conserved.
They're often developmentally canalized
nutations that disrupt such
traits act early in development,
and they can often have
catastrophic consequences.
Adjustable traits react sensitively
to changes in the environment.
They are often controlled by many
genes that have allelic variation.
The disruption of an adjustable trade,
whether it's by genetic mutations
or by environmental insults,
produces diseases of homeostasis
such as diabetes, type two diabetes.